what's up everybody i am just pretty
sing we're here on the iced coffee hour
and we have made what two hundred
thousand dollars wow wow that's that's
fairly close yeah there's a guess they
wouldn't tell me yeah it's a hundred and
twenty four thousand dollars to date
yeah that's good that's good i am so
happy to have you on you have no idea
because i've been watching your channel
for like six years since the very
beginning my man you were wanting to did
it oh gee finance youtubers before
before anyone else i i kid you it was
you
and i think pretty much beat the bush
and then the big names of like tai lopez
grant cardone that was it finance
youtube didn't even exist and you were
making videos back then yeah and you
were one of the first channels that i
came across thank you man
yeah like i would watch your videos and
i didn't even know there was an audience
for this but i think
you maybe had like ten ten thousand
subscribers you're like you were just
starting off and i looked at your
channel i remember thinking like if you
could be getting a few thousand views of
video i at least knew that i could get a
hundred views a video something like
that so are you crushing it man thank
you
thank you man and congratulate you just
hit a million subscribers yeah yeah
thank you thank you it seems like you've
uh grown quite a business from this as
well yeah you've expanded from real
estate
doing this as well yeah investing on the
side so
first of all i want to know your entire
life how did you start making youtube
videos and at what point did you start
investing in real estate you know what
so many i'm going to let you take away
uh i i'm just like you have no idea
because again i've been watching your
channel for a long time it's just i
appreciate it yeah it's nice to be here
with you nice to finally meet you after
years of talking and finally connecting
i don't i didn't know that uh we were
going to connect in vegas but i'm glad
we were able to make it happen
uh i started a minority mindset actually
on accident um i was working on a
different business at the time i was in
law school i got scammed during this
other business that i was running
and i was like this sucks i didn't grow
up with any sort of financial education
i never grew up learning about investing
never grew up learning about money
management never grew up learning about
wealth never grew up learning about
entrepreneurship
and now here i am trying to figure out
this whole entrepreneurship side of
thing i'm seeing success i'm investing
my money that would get scammed and i'm
like god dang it like this is a scam
yeah we gotta know about it we gotta
know about that okay so how did they
scam you i was working on the sock
company and we were getting ready to
launch
and uh
this company comes up to me they're like
all right we're gonna guarantee you all
these sales blah blah blah just pay us
this money and it's a hundred percent
money-back guarantee now i i i'm kind of
uh
like i don't really trust everyone that
comes to me and says that but he was
like it's a 100 money-back guarantee if
you're not 100 satisfied i'll give you
all your money back so okay i gave them
the money and the next day uh i just
like i was like i want to do the
marketing myself i'm a marketing guy
right so i was doing the chest flies and
i was like
something doesn't feel right so i called
him up i was like hey you know i don't
want to go through with this
and he's like okay no problem put me on
hold stay on hold and i'm getting
irritated because i'm like my workouts
getting screwed up so i'm waiting i'm
waiting and waiting and then it just
goes beep
i was like what so i call it this other
number no answer
and that's when i found out i got
scammed i didn't hear from them again um
they took the money and they ran and so
now i launched the business we had a
very successful launch i think we did
like when i was
21 22 000 in pre-orders in the first few
weeks wow so it was a great launch
but i was still like i had that in the
back of my mind i was like this sucks
man
uh getting these type this type of
people out there that are just like
discouraging you from trying to start
something so i went on to udemy and i
created a class and how to launch a
business without getting screwed over
and it was under the alias minority
mindset the whole idea mean you had to
think different than the majority of
people i think i charged like seven
bucks for it i wasn't really trying to
make money it was just like i was so
irritated
and that class got a lot of love and
everyone's like you need to start an
instagram page
okay so i started an instagram page
talking about the same stuff
entrepreneurship financial education and
everyone was like dude your content is
good can you please start a blog like
deeper content i was like english is my
second language you're not gonna like my
writing so no i can't start a blog but
i'll make videos like i like talking so
i just made a youtube channel under the
name minority mindset and i just started
putting out videos here and there and it
was like i didn't know what i was doing
it was just for fun as a hobby
and i remember a few months into it one
of my buddies was like hey man how much
money are you making off of youtube
i was like what are you talking about
he's like from your ads like aren't you
making money
no he's like you know you can turn
monetization on so he goes on to my
channel with me shows me that i can turn
monetization on on my channel i was like
oh i was just doing this for fun i
didn't even know why i could make money
doing this so it started off as a hobby
and now minority monster has grown into
something a whole lot bigger into a full
business
and it's just kind of crazy that it
started off as a hobby
i never expected to be making videos
never expected to be in the financial
education space but here we are now one
of the fastest growing financial
education and media companies so i'm so
curious uh when you started the sock
company first how old were you did you
go to high school did you go to college
yeah did you think you were gonna do you
wanted to sell socks was that a goal no
like 10 years old i'm going to be the
best soccer yeah no so i was uh i was
always an entrepreneur and i started a
lot of different businesses but
i never had any sort of traditional
business education
and so the way i learned was by starting
businesses trying and failing so like my
first real business was when i was in
college i went into college well let me
go back a little bit i was in high
school
i used to work at indian weddings
and um the djs were like hey how about
we start hosting teen parties
i was like okay and now my parents don't
like me doing anything that's not
medical related because they're like you
have to become a doctor so now i'm
hosting these teen parties as a junior
and senior in high school kind of as a
hobby making a little bit of money
and i was like you know this is this is
fun but now i got to go to college let
me settle down go become a doctor and
really just focus on the things that are
going to make me really successful in
life being a doctor
go to college and i had no idea what to
expect my parents did not go to
university here and i didn't really know
anyone that went to college here so i
don't know what college was like in
america i assume that everybody goes to
college to study people spend friday
nights in the chemistry lab studying
go to college and everybody
everybody's around me partying blowing
their money that they don't have florida
state yeah no i'm kidding
i was at the university of michigan and
it was nuts and i couldn't believe it
and i was like well i don't party i
don't drink
but i need something to do on friday
nights
so it's like instead of me you know just
trying to waste my time how about i
start hosting the parties that the
majority of people are going to
so that's what i did i was a freshman i
was 17 years old started knocking on
doors at every club venue bar restaurant
you name it on campus
and some of them would say yeah you can
host a party here but pay me ten
thousand dollars
i only got ten thousand dollars
but some of them would say yeah you can
host a party here just give us half of
the revenue generate half of the cover
charge
all right so now i'm in business 17 i
started hosting these college parties
and that grew when i was in college to
uh
essentially become a full entertainment
company we were hosting parties concert
shows we had events every week i was
contracted by
the biggest venue on campus to host our
college nights every week
and so that was growing and that was how
i had the cash to start investing in
real estate started investing in real
estate when i was 19.
and uh
that was when
now towards the end of college i was
like oh no i don't want to be a doctor
anymore now what how much were you
making then
well
i was making probably on average two
grand an event
and
and uh you know at least one event a
week
my biggest event made me probably
generated right around 16 grand no way
yeah yeah when i was in college how did
you get so many people to show up
man it's marketing right so i was i
so what the first thing that i would do
is all kind of just
how do you now get people to know about
the event and get excited so the first
thing we would do is we'll start
promoting on facebook this is before you
know instagram was popular and all this
facebook used to be the thing wait a
second i remember i've i haven't used
facebook in a while i remember get you
would go to the the events yes
wow and you couldn't you could invite
other people to be if oh my i forgot now
you know the business behind it that was
a major thing i remember for me in high
school because it's like i remember like
the the best parties i wasn't a part of
your in high school but you'd want to
get invited to these certain parties and
they would all do it through facebook
yeah and it was like you had to get the
invite and sometimes you'd be like yo
man uh could you invite me to that thing
and they'd have to go on theirs like
because then you'd be in the chat people
don't do that anymore but facebook
yeah it was huge so what we would do the
first thing is we would go if the event
was in september we would look at all of
our friends birthdays in september
because facebook tells you this and we
message each and every one hey it's your
birthday month what we're going to do is
we're going to give you free vip access
into our party it doesn't cost me
anything
but we want to celebrate with you we're
going to give you a shout out so the
dj's going to announce your name and say
happy birthday to you at the party
they're going to say okay now if they
come to celebrate at the party they get
to come in for free but no one comes to
celebrate alone so they're going to
bring all their friends so then what i
would do is i would get kind of
promoters at every major campus around
us so these promoters were popular kids
and
all they wanted was free access into the
party because if you came in as a vip
you would get a lanyard that would cost
me like three dollars so i'd give you a
three dollar land you get to come in for
free it doesn't cost me anything but now
what you're gonna do is i'm gonna give
you a stack of flyers and you're gonna
tell all your friends because you know
you're that person and you want to be
that cool person and so they would start
telling all their friends to start
coming to the party so now i got like
these essentially sales people these
agents in different universities
promoting and then i would spend a
hundred dollars it used to cost me a
hundred dollars to print five 000 flyers
for the party
and before the event it was a
requirement that we had to get rid of
all 5 000 of these flyers so everywhere
i mean we would post these flyers
everywhere
and so it's just word of mouth getting
things getting people excited coming up
with different themes different ideas uh
partnering with different organizations
and and yeah man i mean it was just it
was just a matter of being creative just
like anything else but first i want to
thank our sponsor alex i do the intro to
the sponsors how many times do i have to
tell you dude but it's coinbase coinbase
is our sponsor yes oh my thanks coinbase
coinbase offers a trusted and very easy
to use platform to buy sell and spend
cryptocurrency they support the most
popular digital currencies on the market
and make them accessible to everyone so
if your gram is asking you about the new
cryptos it's likely they're on coinbase
they also have a mobile app which lets
you trade securely and monitor your
crypto all in one place well alex no
wonder you were so excited to do the
intro seriously guys everyone here at
this house loves coinbase i use it jack
uses it graham uses it even bailey uses
it and it's easy to see why millions of
people in over 100 different countries
trust coinbase with their digital assets
and for a limited time new users who
sign up get ten dollars in free bitcoin
that's right ten dollars in free bitcoin
all you gotta do is go to coinbase.com
ich and it's for a limited time so be
sure to do it today that's coinbase.com
ich thank you so much coinbase for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
could there have been any liability
issue like if your parties get a little
too crazy
every night i was a bouncer every day so
it was i mean look i'm gonna tell you
i'll be completely straight up it was
dangerous and that's one of the reasons
why i got out uh because
the first party i did there was an issue
with um there was some uh beef going on
between some people that came and me and
my dj friends someone pulled a gun no
way yeah or and so
you know we had to get out of there um
every night i was a bouncer i i you know
i got into a lot of kind of
altercations um i don't really no one
didn't like me i was i
was able to get along with everybody but
there's people that didn't like each
other so i had to you know kind of
separate that
and i mean just to kind of put it in
perspective uh you know i went to a club
one day uh to go talk to the owner
because we were doing an event soon i
was like you know where's where's this
guy and he's like oh he got stabbed last
night so you know i'm in place for him i
was like whoa
so that was one of the things that we
always kept a knife on us
um at the dj booth so it was it was a
rough business man like it wasn't easy
but for me like i'm just getting started
it was a hustle
and
that was kind of what i knew i did not
want to be in this business anymore i
mean i didn't like the partying i didn't
like the drinking i didn't like the
environment but for me it was like i'm
making money for the first time and it
taught me a lot and it gave me the
education taught me how to speak with
people
and that kind of set me up for a whole
lot of other things but yeah i mean in
terms of liabilities you know i'm an
attorney now and i shake my head because
i do it like the dumb things that i did
like i am so fortunate that like you
know things worked out
and yeah i mean it's it's unfortunate
you know when people get too intoxicated
they do some dumb things and it's just i
don't like that industry which is why i
got as far away from it as possible i
don't like it but it was it was kind of
like the only thing that i knew and
that's how i started
but six figures in college doing that as
a side gig while studying is just it's
it's working a lot man
yeah no kidding how many hours you're
putting into that a lot let me put it in
perspective like fridays if i had an
event on a friday my class all day i'll
be planning the event so from morning to
evening you know i'm just working party
starts at 10 p.m so 8 p.m i'm gonna go
to the venue and start setting up party
starts at 10. i'm there till 2
after 2 that's when everything gets
kind of torn down make sure everything
is okay and then 3 3 30 i got to make
sure the dj's get paid everyone gets
paid 3 30 we leave
probably get some food
go to sleep around 4 4 30 in the morning
wow and then the next morning saturday
and i'm working on the wedding business
people get married on saturdays so then
i got to be setting up early in the
morning so i got to be at the venue
probably 8 a.m
to start setting up and now i'm at the
venue until
midnight
because you got to set up go through the
entire event make sure the event is all
good
midnight you're done now you tear down
and then now you go home you know 1 2
a.m which is now sunday morning
wake up the next morning start studying
and start the next week start planning
for the next week so i mean i wasn't
sleeping much but it was you know it's
that hustle you got to be willing to put
in that i put in and that was kind of
like
how i learned how it started and then it
built kind of the whole foundation for
everything else so it's kind of weird
that you know i never thought that this
event planning thing would have ever
become anything
but it was it was a lot of education
that i got out of it yeah for the work
ethic though were you always like that
or did you have an example of like your
parents worked really hard so you kind
of took after that or did so my parents
came to this country with very little my
dad came to this country with uh less
than a hundred dollars they didn't know
the language didn't really know the
people they don't know the culture so he
had to bust his butt and he always told
me you know i didn't spend a lot of time
on my parents when i was growing up
because they were always working and my
dad always told me there's no such thing
as a sick day if you take a sick day
you're not working you're not working
you're not getting paid you don't get
paid you don't got money to eat so that
told you jack you told me that mr
vacation in maui next weekend yeah jeez
so yeah i kind of i i saw that and the
hustle i always wanted to give back to
my parents i wanted to give back to my
family
and even my grandparents my grandparents
were refugees
my family is from a state in india
called punjab
and in 1947 my grandparents were on the
left side the west side of punjab and
the state of punjab was severed by the
government and what they said was if
you're a sikh a person of my religion
and you're on the west side of a job you
got to migrate east or you're going to
be killed
and so my grandparents picked up and
they ran my grandfather all he had was a
shirt on his back and a sword in his
hand
they they saw a lot of rooting looting
they saw a lot of riding
um he got attacked
by a mob
he saw his uncle get his head chopped
open right ahead
and uh yeah so they put him on a horse
came to the other side of india now
didn't even have shoes on his feet he
lost his shoes along the way and now i
had to start off from scratch so then
you know i was i grew up with my parents
and my grandparents
um they lived with me so like they kind
of always told me this
the things that they had to go through i
saw what my parents had to go through
you know i didn't grow up poor or broke
or anything like that but i saw the
meaning of hard work and so
i didn't really know what i wanted to do
but i knew i was going to be willing to
work hard to get it because i didn't
have this sort of you know business
background but i was willing to work to
learn it
and so uh that was kind of the
foundation and then when i got to
college my my buddy of mine a dj friend
of mine he gave me an auto audio cd by
uh eric thomas a motivational speaker
and man i used to listen to the thing
every day and that was like okay i gotta
work hard and then once you start
working hard you start to see more
opportunities then you start to realize
okay how do i work smart you got to know
how to do both that we can get the best
results out of your hard work
but you must have like like how did you
learn about the financial education
because you said you bought your first
rental property at 19. yeah so this was
at the bottom of the 2008 crash you
probably remember yeah and so so i'm
guessing this was from your you're
working through college right yep yep so
i had some money put away okay and i'm
in michigan and michigan was hard gm
chrysler and ford are the biggest
employers and they were back then gm and
bankrupt chrysler went bankrupt ford is
on the verge of bankruptcy so michigan
was hit hard i had no idea what was
going on i didn't know any real estate
investors i didn't know what real estate
investing was i started reading business
books money books and every book said
wealthy people invest in real estate i
don't know what that meant but i was
like okay this sounds cool let me do
that too
so now here i am i'm 19 i'm studying for
the medical college admission test the
mcat
and you know i've read these books about
real estate and every time i take a
break
i go into yahoo finance and the top
articles are always real estate market
is at rock bottom i was like okay so
what do i do about this i was like you
know i want to do something
so i told my dad it's like dad i want to
start investing in real estate i was
like you're stupid go study become a
doctor you know he didn't have any
financial education they wanted the best
for me
and i was like you know but i want to do
this so i started calling up different
people agents and i was like okay i
wanna start looking at real estate
and i found this condo on sale a 1 000
square foot condo one bedroom one bath
in a great location next to a lot of
stores a lot of businesses nearby
and it was on sale for 8 400
and i was like oh i don't know anything
better i looked at some other properties
a thirty thousand dollar home a forty
thousand dollar home like it wasn't
anything out of the ordinary so i saw it
i was like okay this is pretty good
doesn't need a lot of work
um i put an offer for four thousand
and we started settling they came down
to seven and then they said uh there's a
bidding there's another offer on the
table and i was like okay well i don't
want to lose this property so i made an
offer for eight i was like i'll give you
a little bit more kind of uh negotiated
and they accept it so i bought the condo
for eight run a few thousand dollars
with the work
and i rented it out for 600.
and now all of a sudden i'm in business
i'm like wait
what is this
this is passive income like it took me a
while to understand like the things i
went through a lot of crap but once i
got the hang of it i was like wait i'm
making like a little bit of money here
and i don't got to really do anything
like it's it's like i own the asset the
assets paying me why was i never taught
this
why did our schools never teach us about
investing i mean i went through i was a
good kid in school i i lost my butt i
checked all the boxes but i never
learned to think about passive income i
never learned to think about investing i
never learned a thing about wealth i
never learned to think about
financial freedom why what the heck am i
doing in school and everyone says oh you
don't got to worry about money money
doesn't matter don't don't don't think
about the money just do follow your
passion
if money doesn't matter then tell your
boss not to pay you right like i mean it
has some like the reason why you're
going to school is to become successful
that way you can be financially free and
the way for you to really not worry
about money is if you're wealthy that
you don't really care about money
because then you know you've already
become wealthy and so that's kind of the
real disconnect that made me really
upset and i was like this is something's
wrong here
there's a reason why so many people are
broke there's a reason why so many
people are struggling with their money
it's because we we are insecure about
our money we don't want to talk about it
and then we put up smoke screens don't
worry about money don't talk about money
but i'm saying let's let's change that
how about we start talking about money
let's get financially educated and let's
see how now we can take care of
ourselves we can take care of our our
families and our community by becoming
wealthy ourselves
because if you understand money you can
do a whole lot more and you don't got to
have all that sort of stress now i agree
money isn't everything it's one part of
our lives but if you don't have money it
can really impact the rest of your life
right so that's where it's like you know
the whole financial education importance
really started hitting me there because
i was like this is
so screwed up but first i want to thank
ladder for sponsoring this episode of
the podcast all the recent holiday
festivities and getting to spend time
with my friends and family it really
reminded me of how fragile life really
is plus with the rising cost of living
and buying a house soon i really don't
want to leave my partner with a huge
financial burden and on that note it
makes sense why people get life
insurance especially term coverage which
is surprisingly affordable and why not
pay a little bit each month to protect
the ones that you love if you're asking
yourself this question choose ladder now
ladder basically took the life insurance
industry flipped it upside down and then
shook out all of the inefficiencies jack
i wish i could do that to you because
you've been taking way too many breaks
not the time or the place alex anyway
before ladder if you wanted life
insurance you would have to drive all
the way across town sit through some
boring sales pitch and fill out a
mountain of paperwork just to wait six
to eight weeks to see if you've been
approved and now with ladder you can get
fast and affordable term life insurance
without ever leaving home because if you
apply for 3 million or less in coverage
it's all 100
digital no doctors no needles no
paperwork so if you're between the ages
of 20 and 60 which statistically you
should be based off of our viewer
demographics and you want to work with a
company that is revolutionizing the life
insurance industry choose ladder go to
ladderlife.com iced coffee today to see
if you are instantly approved that's
ladderlife.com
iced coffee ladderlife.com iced coffee
thank you so much letter for sponsoring
this episode and back to the podcast
the biggest liability for young people
nowadays millennials student loans right
it's like student loans are what we are
supposed to get in order to get educated
so we can get a good job but then i
started lurking more into that and the
number one asset for the united states
government
are student loans otherwise something's
not added up here because the government
keeps talking about how student loans
are a problem we have the student loan
crisis millennials cannot buy homes
because student loans millennials cannot
afford to build wealth because student
loans but at the same time the
government's saying it's our number one
asset
it is the thing that is funding so many
government operations
and now they're saying it's a problem
like it just doesn't make sense and
that's when i was like
you have to start doing your own
education and you need to start thinking
outside of the box right that idea of
thinking differently to the majority of
people and that's when i really started
kind of
going out of my way to learn things that
the majority of people don't talk about
they were not told to think about
kudos to you man for on going on your
own and finding a rental property
without any like influence of your
parents or anything at the age of 19
while going to school studying probably
full-time while working and doing this
insane like
business that you're doing on the side
throwing parties that's actually that's
that's amazing and also that seven or
eight thousand dollar house what was
your like monthly mortgage payment on
that like 60 what a cash cash what a
cash
i called up a bank i was like i want to
get a mortgage the college is the home 8
000. they were like
yeah
what they told me i remember they were
like we can't give you a mortgage on a
home unless it's at least 30 grand and i
was like oh jack consider this let's say
eight grand he's gonna put down a
thousand and then on seven thousand
dollars let's just say this he's gonna
pay a 500 appraisal uh he's gonna pay a
500 bucks to the title company he's
going to pay
so much money on the back end uh
i would say that your expenses would be
like twenty five hundred dollars
seven thousand dollar more expensive i
overlooked that yeah that's uh so so you
were basically making what six hundred
dollars a month use that i rented out
for 600 and half of that was was profit
you know what's crazy i i remember back
then in detroit they were giving away
the the famous one dollar homes yeah and
you could buy a home for a dollar and
believe it or not they had such a
difficult time even with that because
people didn't want to fix up the home so
the stipulation was that uh you could
buy a home for a dollar but you had five
years to fix it up and it usually it's
gosh i'm guessing it needed between
probably 10 and 25 000 at least right a
lot of them were actually just just full
demolitions you had to break down the
home for it to be worth anything yeah
and that's where people were like
it's not worth it yeah these houses had
like no copper piping there were no
fixtures it was basically just uh a
shell of a house basically just the
walls
and a foundation that was probably
cracked but uh yeah a dollar to buy a
house do you be all in like 35 grand
that's amazing and what do you think
those like dollar homes would be worth
now well i bought i bought a lot a
number of homes so i started buying a
number and like i'll put it in
perspective
i took my mom on some of these rental
property tours and
these were five thousand dollar homes
and my mom's like oh my god it's
disgusting don't buy this home and those
homes that were five are probably worth
close to a hundred now uh they probably
needed like 15 worth of work 10 15. like
it was like a broken carpet i mean like
dirty carpet ugly walls but
yeah i mean a lot of the homes that i
bought then are worth
five to 10x what i bought up for which
is just i mean it's insane like because
i didn't really know what i was doing i
was fortunate regarding the time like
when i started buying
but like yeah i made a ton of mistakes i
i made a lot of screw-ups but you know
that's how you learn detroit was one of
the areas that was so hard hit it was
the hardest hit i think anywhere in the
us i think uh florida i think miami was
like the other the other place but but
detroit was the hardest hit area in the
u.s and i remember back then that a lot
of people thought detroit would never
come back because they thought well if
ford goes out of business uh these car
cars like like that's that was the
entire job market basically just was
decimated yeah and they're thinking
who's ever going to come to detroit
anymore what's what's the what's the
appeal it's got it went it got so bad
and properties were were foreclosed on
for a year like five years yeah um and
we're just in such disrepair that people
were like even
bankrupt yeah detroit went bankrupt
it was nuts man i mean and it's
unfortunate all the the stuff that
people went through the things that the
the people of detroit all the crap that
they went through the school system
still is going through a lot of problems
even now so i visited with kevin uh i
think it was three years ago and even
then i mean this this there's some parts
that just have not recovered yeah there
was a proper house fire yes that someone
lit on their own right multiple houses
so we went to uh well we were driving
down the freeway and we literally see
this like
spumis smoke that's piling up and
kevin's like we should go see what that
is
and so we drive down there and sure
enough it's this house that's on fire
like and i've never seen a house on fire
before where like there's actually
flames like coming out of the roof and
everything and it's nuts and we got
there before the um the like the fire
truck or anything got there and so we're
so kevin's talking to the neighbors i'm
like you know we just watch from the car
uh see what's going on now this is an
empty house by the way so this is not
like someone's house that was burned
down it was in this community of maybe
100 maybe 100 houses and i want to say
probably 80 percent of them were vacant
nobody there um but sure enough kevin
starts talking to people and they say oh
yeah i know this is another one this day
we have someone someone around here
who's bored and they go and just burn
down these houses and so we're like what
that's horrible it's like that that's
their that's so anyway so this house is
burning down
and meanwhile a house like kind of five
houses away starts going up in flames as
well like you saw this all happening
yeah oh my gosh oh yeah it's all on
video it's all on video and so then the
fire truck gets there they're putting
out this house the other house starts
going up in flames so then they're like
they call for more and they start going
the other house
and then about 30 minutes later another
house
burns down and uh again they're all
vacant houses and they're all in
disrepair so then kevin starts talking
to the people and they say yeah it's
probably someone who's watching right
now because this seems to be a common
occurrence where people will be bored
they'll burn down a house and then
they'll watch the the fire get put out
basically now i'm looking at some of
these houses and thinking well you know
for for the owner if they have insurance
on the house i mean they'll they'll be
able to rebuild it and a lot of these i
think we're at the point where it would
be hard to salvage yeah probably so
they'd have to be torn down it was
actually a common problem where people
would their homes would get burned down
for the insurance claim it was a big
problem because that's the only people
were able to get money in some instances
and and people were doing that and it
became a huge scandal and it was it was
a big thing man it was horrible yeah so
i wouldn't be surprised because uh the
thing is like it would cost
to rebuild a house like that like 250
grand maybe 300 000
but a house in the area would sell for
35.
so it doesn't make you building a 300
000 home in an area that's worth 50 max
brand new
doesn't make sense so what do you do
you're paying property taxes on
basically an empty parcel of land you
can't do anything with you can't sell it
you have a mortgage on it are you going
to claim bankruptcy so i wouldn't be
surprised if property taxes are not
cheap in detroit what are they
like i bought a home in detroit one time
i think i paid 30 for it 30 grand
and my property taxes were 3 500 a year
wow
because so nobody was paying property
taxes and so if you were especially if
you were an investor so i made it
well i don't know if i made a mistake i
did the right thing
i registered my property as an
investment as a rental property and
everybody everybody told me don't do
that they're like nobody checks nobody
cares i'm like i don't like to play
these games i like to do things the
right way
so i filed it as a rental property and
then they jack up your your taxes it
makes sense 10
i mean i don't even know how much it was
a lot but but in general property taxes
in detroit a lot because a lot of people
were not paying
and so i mean it was it was expensive uh
but you know it was
detroit's been through a lot of hardship
but the people of detroit are tough man
they are the sense of community there
was so strong unlike any other area like
twitter
yeah la people close off the dirt like i
didn't really know any of my neighbors
in all life this is like that's the way
it is but detroit like everyone knows
each other yeah uh there's a strong
sense of community the neighbors
actually hang out they they look over
each other it's it's it's pretty cool
yeah man detroit hustles all right they
do
what was it like going through the 2008
recession in detroit like what did you
see in your own personal life how was
how things were affected i mean
personally like i was young i was in
high school until 2009. so i didn't
really know what was going on because i
wasn't even into finance until after
right so like 0.809 like i remember
people talked about stock market crash
whatever i don't know what that is i put
a little bit of money into ford because
uh i liked ford mustangs and i couldn't
get one so i i i was like what's the
next best thing let me put a little bit
of money into the ford uh stock and so
uh
that was really all that i knew i didn't
know too much of what was going on i
remember in college
there was a big thing of people not
being able to get jobs after because
like the job market was
horrible so like
it was not uncommon for people to go to
college graduate and then say
i'm unemployed like that was just like
the common thing to do
so that's what i remember
and you know just the real estate market
like i remember like i didn't know
i didn't know what was normal and what
was not like to me a 30 000 home and a
good area was like normal i didn't seem
like anything out of the ordinary
because that's all i saw and then when i
saw homes go up to like 50 grand i was
like i don't want to buy that that's too
much money that's too much money and now
those homes are you know 150 but like
it's like i didn't know what was going
on and you know michigan has really come
back
um especially even on the rental real
estate side man real estate properties
are really gone up um not just in the
2020 2021 era but like
like after like things that really
established michigan businesses have
really diversified things that really
come back in michigan it's it's uh it's
cool and detroit is sweet man detroit is
cool like it is a lot of cool things
happening in detroit so next time you're
over there hit me up man oh absolutely
we'll go look at some real estate over
there
it was fun i i really enjoyed my visit
there yeah it was cool so it's not vegas
but it's cool so how many properties do
you own now um
something in the dozens
yeah but it makes up single family homes
mix of uh multi-family
i i did own a mixed use
which is like you know mix of commercial
real estate and then i was actually
going to buy
an a commercial office building for the
first time
last year but then i decided not to i
was gonna i was gonna
um have part of it be our office and
then the other part would be
other offices
but then you know just office mortgages
work very differently than reasonable
residential mortgages
so uh i couldn't get a fixed rate for
longer than five years it was a five
year and then they had to re re-uh
re-amortize yeah re-adjust it and i was
like
i don't know like
interest rates are going to go up
i don't know what's going to happen to
the office market like if this one of
these tenants leave i don't know how
long it's going to take me to find
another tenant
so that kind of just i don't know what
was you know the office chain market is
changing
so i kind of focusing on the residential
side
so apartments single families and
detroit so i was talking to a different
guy yesterday
and the detroit market is michigan
market in general not just detroit but
the michigan market midwest market is
different because
uh they're strong cash flow markets
where you buy a property let's say you
buy a home single family home for 150
grand
that home is going to rent up for 1500
easily um and and and so now you're
going to profit if you buy the home cash
half maybe more than half um and so it's
strong cash flow you don't see the same
appreciation that you would see in some
other places like maybe vegas or austin
uh but you see strong cash flow and so
it's a very different like the mark the
real estate investors in michigan are
very different than the real estate
investors and like you know your hotter
places in like texas arizona vegas like
people and those are looking for how
much can i sell this property for in a
few years versus in michigan they're
saying how much cash flow can i generate
yeah so it's a very different game
wouldn't there come a time like kind of
soon after graduating where you'd have
like five or six investment properties
and you'd be making you know a solid
like five grand or so per month
yeah but you know
i mean do you want to stop there and
retire i mean i'm like 22 years old i
want to live on the beach for the rest
of my life right
i'm just saying i want to i wanted to do
something bigger and you know and i
enjoy entrepreneurship right it's not
just for money it's really like i like
entrepreneurship because
entrepreneurs are in the business of
solving problems i like the idea of
solving problems i love working with
entrepreneurs
and i just love that mentality of
entrepreneurship so like that's why i'm
investing in entrepreneurs now it's like
something that i enjoy doing so for me
entrepreneurship is more than just like
you know how much money can i make
because it's how do i solve a problem i
mean i love the idea of just talking
business and networking and and coming
up with business ideas and trying to
take a product that solves a problem to
market and doing all that so i enjoy it
and i i like having the fun it's like
one of the things that i talk about is
retirement is stupid the traditional
concept of retirement i'm gonna work a
job for 45 years just so i can
ultimately quit and sit on my butt for
the rest of my life it doesn't make any
sense and that's why people say
those who retire early die early because
when you sit on your butt when you're 65
years old and do nothing you have no
purpose
you know you feel miserable
so i i love entrepreneurship and i mean
i work a lot but like
i don't think i would change what i do
like this is what i want to do for the
rest of my life because i love
entrepreneurship i love working with
entrepreneurs i i just enjoy it
so that's what i would do i mean that's
why you know you never stop
yeah so you started the channel then so
first of all getting a getting a law
degree how difficult was that not as
hard as building a youtube channel
uh not taking the passing the passing
the bar exam and everything did you go i
did i passed the bar i did everything
and you know that was that was tough um
but
you know the difference between starting
let's say a youtube channel or a
business
then
becoming an attorney
is
uh becoming an attorney it's it's you
read a textbook
you analyze it and then you break it
down right so it's like it's it's in a
textbook
now you got to be able to think
but
it it's it's you if you read this and
you understand this you can answer the
question
with business or youtube it doesn't work
like that like you could try something
it might not work like there's no you
either do this or you don't do this
right you have to be creative
so that's what makes uh youtube
difficult is you know it you have to be
a lot more creative you have to be
willing to take risks you have to be
willing to try things
and
if you don't have that ability to kind
of try and that creative mindset it's
going to be much harder for you
especially to build on youtube got it so
when you started monetizing on youtube
in the very beginning how much were you
making back then oh man i think it took
me
a year and almost a month when i got my
first check because it took me a long
time before i got to get to a hundred
dollars
yeah it took me a year and uh almost a
year so let's just say a year and a half
and my first check was 2400
something around there so it took me a
year and a half to make 2400 bucks
wow
and then at what point did you start
saying that you're making enough on this
to really spend time on it or were you
just doing it doing it for fun it was
still for fun i was still working on
other businesses so i was like this was
just like something i was just doing i
was like okay whatever i'm making a
little bit of money here because i mean
if i was an attorney i'd be charging 250
an hour
you know versus 2500 over a year so i
mean i was just doing this kind of for
fun
and then it was really the stock
business was doing well it was making
good money
um and we were working on a lot of
different deals
but then uh we had a patent that was
denied
and now i was like okay cotton what sort
of so it was a water resistant sock how
how could you can you how did you make
that so
uh it was a good idea how is nobody
seriously how many times do you get your
because getting your sock wet is
probably the most annoying thing exactly
that's the worst i could because then i
have to switch out my socks there's no
easy way to dry it yeah exactly i've
stepped like sometimes like bailey's
water dish will kind of spill and i step
on like a little bit
that's the most annoying thing right
yeah so i got the idea i was taking a a
speech class in college and one of the
classes was you need to pitch a product
to the class i was like that's easy i
love coming up with product ideas i do
this with my friends all the time so i
put it off i put it off i put it off
one day i was late to class
and um i picked up my backpack and i
started running and it was raining and i
stepped on a pothole on the way i'm a
foot soaked got to class my feet's wet
and i was like oh man like whatever like
just sit down and the teacher's like
just pretty are you ready
like ready for what she's like today's
your day to present i was like oh no i
forgot so i'm standing in front of class
i was like just pretty think of
something think of something anything
first thing that comes to my mind were
my wet socks so i just pitched this idea
of wet socks to the class
and um
and i was like well that's kind of a
cool idea why doesn't this exist just
like what you said
so then i thought about it and i was
like well this could potentially give me
the scalability and all this other stuff
that i was looking for
so then um i started working at it and
you know i started looking learning
about the stock industry started talking
to stock manufacturers and they had no
idea about how to do that so then i
started learning about the actual
textiles so i started talking to textile
engineers and cotton producers and how
do we now produce this type of
technology now this waterproofing
technology exists already but it doesn't
exist and it didn't exist in socks so i
was like how about we integrate this
waterproof technology into socks
so i was kind of working with textile
engineers sock manufacturers trying to
put this together
and that's essentially what we did we
created a yarn that had this waterproof
technology into it and then when you put
on the sock it would repel water
and so it was doing really good we were
working with you know some
schools we're working with a lot of
athletes working with a lot of different
people we actually
i was reached out to by a lot of venture
capital people and one company was
trying to get us in contact with under
armour
but they were like you know we need to
make sure you get a secured patent
before i present this
and because like my goal wasn't to be in
the sock business i wanted to license
the technology and the whole business of
selling it was just proof of concept
that now we can take this to bigger
brands and say hey licenses from us
and uh
then when the patent got denied because
they're like it's not an original enough
idea because the waterproofing exists
you're just putting it into socks when
the patent got denied that's and i was
like okay what do i want to do do i want
to be in the you know business of just
building a brand building a stock
company or do i want to be in the
business of you know doing something
else so
minority mindset wasn't making any money
saw a company was making good money
but i was like what do i do
and so i was like let me start putting a
little bit more time at the minority
mindset because i love like the
financial education side of things this
this is like fun i could do this all day
and night long you know socks yeah i
love the idea of building a business but
how excited can you really be about
socks
so i started spending more time in
minority mindset and uh started to grow
this is probably around one or two
hundred thousand subscribers so we're
making a little bit of money i don't
remember how much but a little bit um
but i was like you know let me let me
try to just just turn this into
something else so that's when
we started adding other things to it
built the newsletter built the blog
built other you know things around there
and that's kind of how we started isn't
there a way to patent that stock idea
though because i'm going back you're
like you can't waterproof that but
couldn't you find a way to like
waterproof
a sock with a sole at the bottom of it
that makes it not slippery and like
something like like you put like little
rubber things there aren't there easy
ways around patents you know
patents are not easy to deal with that's
why patent attorneys cost a lot of money
but if you want to try it man go for it
i'll support you
that's what we have to do
some water because because i've seen but
i've also seen the flip side where
patents um are bitten i don't wanna say
patents are worthless but then you have
to spend money defending them because
somewhat let's say you have like the
rubber soles at the bottom and that gets
patented some other company would be
like well it's not rubber it's this
other material and because it's not
exactly that then technically we could
do it they're going to change one thing
they change one thing and then you have
to sue them and then it's like a 50 50
if you even win is it worth defending no
so
so how much money were you making from
your sock company right when you decided
to spend more time into mine i don't
remember exactly but it was it was a
good amount of money it wasn't the six
figures i don't remember exactly what it
was but i was making pretty solid money
like and i was a really young kid i had
no expenses
yeah that was taken away so it was
good money there that's like even let's
say 150
that's a significant amount of money to
be like no i'm not gonna i don't want to
sell socks but he also had real estate
and like he said yeah but end goal well
that's what i was doing right i was
taking the money and buying real estate
that's all i was doing i i was living
very small i wasn't spending money i i
wasn't just all i was doing was buying
real estate i think it would be super
fascinating if you could go over your
income over time and how it's changed
from certain like sources to other
sources
well
let's see i go back to high school in
high school
i was working in the wedding business
and when i first started i used to
charge fifty dollars for an hour or
whatever it was to me i split drum
called the dole
and um
i just i would charge fifty dollars to
do that and then i started working on
tien's pretzels i was making five
dollars and 45 cents an hour because i
was under 18 so they were like well we
can pay you less even though i was doing
all the work the manager would sit there
take the landline phone go talk
uh to someone else and i'm sitting here
we're running the whole store making
five dollars or some change but i was
like whatever i learned
and then towards the you know when i
started college
uh i was probably charging 200 250 bucks
to go work at weddings for an hour if i
worked the whole day 600 bucks or so 250
for like one or two hours and six
hundred dollars for the whole day
um and then what was that was that like
uh video
i played the drum the drum and then i
used to work with djs so i would help
them set up help them tear down pretty
much just kind of be their assistant
right just making sure everything goes
everything goes yeah okay so i did that
um and then
i was running parties well the first
event was a flop i lost a lot of money
on the first event
but then that started to grow
towards the end of college is when it
really started to ramp up so now we're
talking you know a couple grand an event
and then got into wholesaling
again kind of starting over so now you
know a little bit of income from real
estate but then you start wholesaling
wholesaling and selling real estate
so wholesaling didn't make me any money
for a little while then it started
making me um you know you're another
10 000 something a month or something
like that you know
something like that
and then from wholesaling uh
again now i'm just trying to buy more
real estate
and then i had i can man i gotta like
think about this which businesses that i
did after what because i had an amazon
company when i was in college i started
a t-shirt company because uh this was
like
like pretty much my whole idea of
entrepreneurship was whenever there's an
opportunity
try to solve that problem what about
throughout your youtube channel because
when you started
you posted consistently i think it was
what twice a week
yeah i think i started twice a week the
movie three now we're at five yep
monday through friday right monday
wednesday thursday friday sunday so we
got a little break on tuesday saturday
okay
how is your business broken down on
youtube because i know you have the
channel yeah you have the newsletter
right uh what else is there that i'm
missing so we have the channel yeah we
have the newsletter like you talked
about we have two different newsletters
we have like a daily breakdown of the uh
the market so every day let's say it's
tuesday you'll get a breakdown of what
happened on monday and this is like a
fun video newsletter you can read in
like five minutes that will break down
everything that you need to know in the
market because no one wants to read wall
street journal cnbc yahoo finance all
that so it's a breakdown of all that
then we have more of an educational
newsletter
uh so we have these two newsletters that
go out then we have our blog um so our
blog we we have like maybe a dozen or so
writers right now um these are people
that write content daily for our website
dozen people yeah and um the most most
of them are not full-time these are like
freelancers we have our editors are
full-time that are viewing them but most
of the the writers are not full-time
um but they're writing articles
um so our website is content daily
um and then we have uh obviously
sponsorships but then we have we just
launched an academy we call it market
insiders so it's like a weekly coaching
for stocks in real estate we plan on
adding cryptozone and it's super
affordable and that was the main thing
for me for that
47 a month how many people do you have
in there so we're just started we just
finished up our beta um and when we we
launched it and i think within a month
and some change we had just over 100
users
or 100 people that are in the program
but that was a brand new thing that we
just started because we have some other
education programs that we did
but i wanted to make something that was
super affordable because those education
programs were great they were like for
the business side i mean they were doing
great like multiple six figures but like
it didn't provide me kind of the goal
exactly that i was looking for because
like even in business
we see a lot more benefit when people
have true coaching
where it's like
it's not just i give you a class we give
you consistent like every week you get
access to more information that way you
have like checks and balances someone's
making sure that you you know you have
someone to talk to and you keep getting
that refresher or what's going on as
opposed to just throwing it on you and
you're doing it yourself
so that's the whole idea behind market
insiders where it's like learn how to
invest in stocks from somebody who has
six figures or seven figures so we're
talking hundreds of thousands if not
millions of dollars in the market
someone has been doing this for a long
time and you can learn from them and
every week you get access to coaching
get access to your community uh we have
our own discord and you get a free class
as soon as you join and you get access
to all the previous recordings and like
it's like for me it's to make it a
no-brainer where it's like if that's
still not enough try it for free you
have a free 10-day trial go through the
entire program then you can see if it's
right for you or not and if you hate it
just quit i'm curious for the newsletter
what made you want to start a newsletter
well we had a financial education
newsletter first where was i kind of
like just
providing more education more in-depth
stuff
and then
i started to see more opportunity on the
financial news that are meaning like the
market briefs we call it
our market breakdown but we do we
started to see opportunity there
because
a lot of other newsletters started to
kind of get some traction so there were
things like you know morning brew the
hustle
finima so a lot of other things started
popping up and we saw robin hood snacks
and doing this we're like we should
really have one for ourselves because
you know we're talking a lot on the
financial side this is about a year ago
i think it was this is more than a year
ago one year yeah yeah so this is a
little while ago um
and so we started just just doing this
that's kind of like
here's a way for you to learn about
what's happening in the world without
having to spend hours trying to decipher
it and actually real time because let's
say i'm making a video on it it might
take me a week just depending on if i'm
not here or whatever is going on don't
miss out so that was the first thing
that we did and we didn't have a way to
monetize that because we didn't really
know what we're going to do but then
started to realize that sponsors wanted
to monetize the newsletters so you know
you get the news that are for free and
then we work with sponsors to now put
advertisements how many uh users did you
have to get in the newsletter to start
getting sponsors like that i think you
can start getting sponsors at like 20
000 subscribers i was speaking with uh
the owner of a morning brew this is a
while ago and it blew my mind just how
uh
first of all how lean they ran the
business but also just how smart they
were and how strategic everything was so
i subscribed to morning group because
they reached out initially and wanted to
do a sponsor yeah and i figured well uh
let me just sign up for them i'll start
reading it and if i like it yeah move
forward to the sponsorship i loved it i
honestly i and i did a great job every
single email it was good
and then i got in touch with adam who's
the owner yeah yeah and so we started
talking and i'm asking him like and we
talked for probably two hours
and like i was talking with him about
the youtube algorithm he was telling me
about the morning brew algorithm and
it's so genius his open rates he was
telling me is somewhere around 50 to it
could be as low as 40 as high as 60
percent sometimes higher and to think
that he they have you know millions of
people subscribed to them and they have
50 of people opening their email every
day
is wild and i didn't realize well i
don't know how much i should give away
on here but anyway he his plan for for
testing out titles and figuring out what
people open is just it's incredible they
sold the company yeah well not not i
don't believe it was the entire thing
but they sold the big chunks of value to
what 70 million 75 million to business
insider i don't know
what their split was or if that i don't
think it was a hundred i could be wrong
but uh
so smart yeah they did a great job they
did it right i mean because they were
really one of the first movers in the
market to really
hit the financial market and make it fun
and entertaining and so you know we we
kind of we learned a lot from them but
then we made it a little bit different
made it our own because the difference
between something like morning brew and
us is you know we have uh people have a
lot of connection with me a minority
mindset right they watch on youtube so
they're like oh we know just breathe so
now we the big thing is you know we have
a big community aspect as well so you
know we have our own community on
discord called guac talk and so you know
we have a real
community in the sense where we bring
people from guac talk onto our
newsletter we bring stuff from our
youtube onto our newsletter so not only
is it the market breakdown but you also
have like a breakdown of what's
happening within the minority mindset
community yeah so it's a little bit
different in that sense where yeah you
have the financial breakdown but you
also have the community breakdown would
you ever sell it
uh we have no thoughts or plans to sell
it right now our goal is really just
build a bigger community it's different
right because minority mindset is a much
more personalized brand yep um and so
you know
we don't have any intention to do that
got it can you share how much the
newsletter is making
it's the ballpark well our i'll tell you
this our break even in order for us to
break even on the newsletter right now
is right around eight grand that's kind
of our cost a month a month
or just a little bit more than eight
grand
and we hit break even
in
i think the first time we hit it was
either late 2020 or early 2021
wow you ran this for a while without
breaking even well because you know it
was just it was an investment right it's
like what do i do with the ad revenue i
can either just go buy you know a house
i can go buy a car i can buy a ford gt
my ford gt or i can reinvest it back
into the brand so we were putting it
back into the minority mindset and
now we're
i mean
we're probably
a couple times that uh
at least where are you investing now
where did your money go today well
invest my money in five places real
estate stocks
businesses cryptocurrency and then
physical commodities like gold physical
gold you buy gold physical gold how old
are you i'm 30. 30. i'm 30. you're the
you're the youngest gold investor i
think i've i've
ever met before gold is in insurance man
for me it's not like i'm not getting a
yield on my gold yeah i'm not getting a
return on it it's just real money
and the way i look at it is the store of
value i mean it takes time effort and
labor to mine gold
uh and it just sits there and look backs
at me you know just it's not doing
anything but i keep it as insurance in
case everything else goes wrong in the
world i got gold what about treasuries
well that's why i own gold
you'd rather if you'd rather have their
own gold than you're trading well why do
i own gold because i'm worried about
inflation if we ever see hyperinflation
well now what happens to treasuries
they're worthless
well i mean gold really hasn't done that
it doesn't yeah and i don't care what
happens ago i don't care if it goes up
or down it's just real money right it's
just like would i rather save dollars
in the bank or under my bed or would i
rather keep gold under my mattress right
i'd rather hold some physical gold
what's what's that in relation to the
total portfolio it's small i'll say
maybe like
i don't even think it's 10 right now uh
but it's it's pretty small that's a lot
yeah even it's i think it's less it's
less than 10. um but it's it's it's the
smallest portion
but that's just kind of like insurance i
put a little bit of money to to gold i
have like a passive thing where every
month i have a little bit of money
buying physical gold and they just send
you gold or they hold it themselves yeah
they hold it in a place
everybody delivered faster
yeah no it just kind of accumulates um
in a vault and then when you have enough
to buy a whole bar
and then they can either ship it out to
you or you can keep it in a vault oh i
see so you're buying it through them
they store it for you yes
it'll upgrade so then you get a bar at
some point yeah i mean i have physical
gold but yeah it's just it's in vaults i
don't keep it under my mattress but
that'd be a little tough on my head but
i have yeah that's what i do with that
and what about krypto what are you what
are you buying in crypto so i buy uh a
passively buying bitcoin ethereum some
of the other uh coins but
that's pretty much it i think it's like
five coins that i'm passively buying and
then you know when prices go down i'll
buy more yeah i think crypto is the
future it's the people's movement of
money
um but i don't think it's gonna go
straight up i think we're gonna see ups
and downs very volatile yeah um and so
you know is there a lot of crap in
crypto yeah i think it's crap in crypto
i think there's a lot of bad coins i
think there's crap coins
but i think there's a lot of opportunity
in future in crypto what percentage of
your portfolio is that just about to ask
that man this is a great question see
these percentages are tough tough
question because i don't like make a
chart of my investments but um
you could just do products yeah i mean
uh so i'll tell you like uh every month
so i have a passive investment i talk
about do stocks and do crypto my passive
stocks and crypto is the same every
month
and then um but what i also do is i have
a big chunk of my money in stable coins
that are earning interest because like
this is like the cash that's like
waiting to be invested interesting yeah
and so what i did was i just moved it
because my bank is paying me you know
0.01
and then i also had a high interest
savings account that i think that was
paying me like i don't know half a
percent like again nothing right um but
then um i was like well what do i do
with the cash that i'm waiting to invest
like i'm looking for opportunities to
invest and so this is the cash that then
i then use to now buy stable coins which
are now paying me i don't know seven
eight nine percent insane i would be
tempted just to put like a million
dollars in stable coins and just
why invest it though because it's like
exactly the biggest risk for me is that
like something like tether something
might happen well don't do tether but
there are what so what stablecoin is
your well i mean okay if you want to
pretend that's fine i i do a few just
because
exactly heather has gone through the
issues of
regulatory issues you know do they
actually have enough dollars right to
that relative number of stable coins so
that's the first concern i know i use uh
the gemini coin
the usdc um and i have i think one or
two others pax um paxos and all that but
so for me yeah it's kind of like
diversification within the stable coins
in that sense um
because yeah you're right something
could go wrong um and so with the stable
coin but then you have the issue of the
counterparty risk if like you know the
institution you're you're keeping your
stable coins at
if they go down or if people don't you
know let's say you see a massive crash
and people don't pay the stable coins
back well they're not fdsc insured so
you know you have the higher risk and
that's you know you said a million
dollars that's good don't put more than
a million because a lot of accounts they
do a million dollar limit that you can
withdraw in a week so it's like okay i
know i ain't putting more than a million
in there i am just so terrified that
like
seven percent sounds insane to me that
sounds really high and i'm worried that
that there's just not enough regulation
to ensure that they're actually putting
that money to good use yeah and if
something happens on that it's gone it's
like
yes how long are you gonna keep the
money in there too right i mean for me i
don't plan on keeping this there for 10
years no but it's ten listen it's it if
i'm getting eight percent of my money
i'm leaving it there i mean
i'll leave enough there where it's like
that's my safety fund no matter what
yeah it's like in the back of my mind
you know it's just it's tight yeah you
can also look at like the previous i
always like kind of look at the
historical like how long has this thing
been here and like a lot of the stable
coins if you remember the 2017-18
bitcoin bubble crash like tether
that went from a dollar to 93 cents so
it dropped by like seven eight percent
which
you don't want to see that happen but
right relative to the grand scheme of
like what happened in the crypto market
it wasn't that bad now let's see okay if
let's assume that this can continue
uh then what's the next risk it's are
these accounts going to be around
because that's the next concern is right
these uh new institutions which allow
you to earn interest they haven't been a
lot around long enough to see a major
downturn
so it's like who are they lending their
money out to because some people are
lending their money out to uh retail
investors
and they're going to pay you a higher
return and others are going to rent it
out to institutional investors so uh big
corporations credited accredited invest
you know institutions so it's like okay
i'm okay not getting 11
because i want to get some seven eight
because i you know i want to know who
they're actually lending the money out
to
so is the risk absolutely man it's risky
i mean the things could go down but it's
like you know you you want to put in
that money where i i don't plan on
keeping it there forever
um but i also i understand hey this is
better than a savings account right i
don't just want to save my money i want
to buy investments but this is money
waiting to be invested this is earning
me something so usually we ask every
guest you don't have to answer this if
you don't want to but
you want to know
how much money you make
well
i don't even know how much money i make
but it's in the millions um
uh i don't know exactly okay
because
i don't spend my money i don't i don't i
don't live off with the money that i
make
i invest it and then uh i i don't live
very big
but like if we have a ballpark we're
like gonna say you know it's millions
could be well pretty big like two
million bucks the first time after after
expense yeah no okay so the first time i
made a million dollars yeah i think i
took home 20 000.
oh because it was you're running this
through the business it was reinvesting
right right into real estate as well
yeah so i mean it's like oh yeah i see
what your point yeah well
reinvesting well i don't think it counts
if it's reinvested into because i could
say that like you know if if you make
five so i invested 4.9 the question is
the better question is how much money am
i living off of and i would say i'm
living off of
less than 150 grand a year
okay how much was that nice suit
looks really nice this was a gift
actually my wife gave me this
let me give this and that's right too
you got married i got married earlier
congratulations yeah i don't we don't
see a ring so that was something you're
in vegas and uh you're not wearing a
ring well my wife is with me i'm here
with my wife in vegas she didn't want to
come she she was busy doing some other
stuff
um but uh yeah you know i actually i did
i wore the wedding ring i couldn't sleep
it was so weird having a ring on yeah
and like i feel i couldn't sleep on it
and for me it's like
it's also kind of goes into a cultural
thing for me it's like
i uh we have this we have a couple of
things like culturally versus
religiously where like religiously it's
like you don't need to have a physical
representation to show your love for
someone
and for me culturally it's i mean in
that sense it's like you know
i love my wife more than anything you
know and
i don't need a ring to show her that and
she she believes me she knows that and
uh i honestly i really don't care if i
wear one or not it doesn't really matter
it just was so uncomfortable to me i
like couldn't even sleep i was like it
was just feeling weird that's the thing
for me like i i've never worn a ring and
just the idea of ever like having a ring
yeah a watch is different but like a
ring i don't know yeah when i get
married um i don't think i'm gonna
wearing and kelsey doesn't even wear
around her engagement ring so
now i'm curious oh wait we'll get to
that in a sec uh as a finance guy did
you decide to do a prenup if you if you
feel comfortable talking about it i'll
glance over it okay i did not get a
prema i'm prenup i'm an attorney and i'm
a finance guy now every attorney is
going to say why did you not do that
well i'll put it this way my wife has
put up with all my crap she put up with
you know me working my butt off
and you know let's just talk worst case
scenario which obviously we hope nothing
ever right obviously we'll talk worst
case scenario
she deserves half
for everything that she's done every
financial person every attorney is going
to say oh you're stupid you don't know
what you know fine it doesn't matter
okay and for me it's you know i
you know it's weird because like you
know we talk about all the stuff and
i come from a a unique cultural
background where like you know we don't
really talk about money that's why i
don't really talk about my personal
finances much because
i don't i don't like showing it it's
just not the way i am right it's not my
culture it's not it's not who i am right
and even like with that it's like you
know i i the one of the things i hate
doing is i hate hard gaining more money
to me that's like it's it's
bad
to your
core and so i don't like arguing over
money i don't like fighting over money i
like educating about money so you can be
free so you can build wealth but i hate
the idea of like that
of tensions over money i like doing
things honestly doing things ethically
because i get my religion right i'll
just talk about that because it is a big
part of who i am there's three core
components nam japo one shaku
nam japo means remember god
one shaku means serve others before you
serve yourself
girl means earn an honest living and so
these things are all very important to
me yeah and that's kind of the way that
i live which is why i don't like to i
don't talk about you know how much money
i make i know it is gonna i wish you did
because it's it's really interesting for
me to hear a different side yeah of you
talking about this because i think it's
it's it not only is it very important
for you but i think also your your
especially your longtime viewers would
be so curious yeah and it just it it
opens up another door
that uh
helps build that familiarity and that
connection with you absolutely and you
know we talk about some of the things
that we do in our business
but you know it's like i come from a
different background yeah and i have a
different personality and so you know
that's just the way i am you know i
don't ever talk about
that type of stuff and said you know you
can you can see some of the things that
i'm doing i'll talk about what i do with
my money i talk about how to invest it
that way you can you know do that but i
don't like
uh the idea of attracting somebody
by showing money you know what i mean i
don't try to attract people i say hey
look i got this money come fall watch me
i don't do that yeah it's not me and so
like can you talk about with the prenup
good question you know
if i was advising somebody as an
attorney i would advise people to get
the prenup right legally it makes sense
financially it makes sense
now personally for me culturally no i i
i
for me personally it does not and so you
know i like to be honest with everything
that i do in that sense i'll tell you
hey look this might be better for some
people this is what i do and i always
say i'll say what i do yeah
i have no problem being honest i have no
problem being completely transparent in
that but it's just the way that i
present myself i do that very
differently just because of where i come
from i respect that a lot that's a great
answer incredible answer actually yeah
not only have you have you not answered
not answered you've answered every
single question that we've asked you but
you if you've answered it in such a
great way yeah let me expand upon that
because you know one of the things that
this actually irritated me before yeah
because i used to uh when i was trying
to get media coverage i would like pitch
these ideas and then the question that
everyone would say is sure but instead
of that idea that you have how about we
talk about how much money you're making
and i turn down every single one
every single time because every single
headline
i mean you can name any media works it
does that's the thing and you know
you're right you're 100 right it does
work every you name the media outlet you
can name it every single one has said it
let's do an article about how much money
you're making as a youtuber yep i've
said no
every single time
every single time why free pr but it's
culturally it's it's not me man okay
it's not me and and that's the thing is
i don't i don't need it i don't need to
do that
and
that's i think that's one of the reasons
people like me because they know that
i'm authentic everything that i say i'm
very genuine i'm very honest
um and everything i say is from my heart
right i speak with passion and so even
with that right like i rejected every
single one because i don't want to talk
about it i don't i don't talk like that
that's not that's not who i am
except on the ice stop copyright
i appreciate a man how about this we're
we're going to be finishing up here ask
us questions what questions do you have
for us
it's a final segment here i also have
one one final question
what is it about you two questions sorry
what is it about you you said one i'm
just kidding sorry
two questions what is it about you that
you've used in all of these different
business ventures that really like makes
you successful with all like what is it
is it your character is it
something about you i think one um
well
one working hard i would say i work
really hard and second i think it's just
creativity like one of our core values
at the minority mindset is crazy as good
and by that meaning trying new things
trying something crazy
and willing to try things that you know
the majority people won't
i think that that's worked well for us
all right and then what's the what's the
bracelet so this again this is a method
religious uh bracelet it's called the
karda so uh this
uh every sick wears it want to identify
there's six but it it's a you put it on
your dominant hand as a reminder to do
good so before i do something bad you
know if you do it with my dominant hand
it's supposed to remind me wow wow
that's interesting it's good oh what
what watch is that
this one is a shinola a detroit brand
so rep in the city that's cool nice give
us some questions if if you have any
yeah let's do you have anything what's
the future
what's everyone's future
of graham stefan i don't know i have no
clue i look up to dave ramsey dr phil
judge judy joe rogan so those people i
look i i really like their careers um
judge judy i would say and dave ramsey
are probably my favorites just because
they've had good longevity um
family friendly everyone could watch
them i like them so i have no idea
so
the next step for me is having alex out
of the main channel videos so i can't
think of anything else i literally it
might
when is enough
what do you mean when's enough like when
when when are you like i never i love
this no no no no no no
i like that answer no no i have so much
fun like uh like i've been trying to get
ahead so i've taken the first vacation
in in like five years like real vacation
uh i think it's for four days
and i've been trying to work ahead like
to get ahead so that those four days i
have everything already done and uh i'm
in the zone like i love it like it's
hard for me to scale back from that and
i'm excited now about being able to get
more done over these next few it's weird
so i like it i dig it yeah i dig it
what's the most you ever spent on
clothes
and clothes with jack bought me the most
expensive pair of shoes i ever have
um jack got me a gift uh
there was a store that we went to and
it's the family vlog which is like our
vlog channel and there were a pair of
shoes that graham really liked they were
like absurdly expensive though like like
six hundred dollars i think they were
absolutely and graham could not justify
spending the money and i remember like i
saw him and i like i sometimes i pushed
graham because if he sees something that
he really wants i'm like dude just going
go ahead and do it like i know it's
off-brand i know it makes you feel
uncomfortable but like if you really
want something you're at the point where
like you've worked so hard you deserve
it right or you've earned it and he
didn't want to but uh it definitely i
was like dang like i wish that he got
those shoes and i still thought about it
and then months later like as a thank
you for letting me stay at his place
because i just got my own place i got
him the the pair of shoes it's his most
expensive
but he has expensive watches that he
buys yeah
those are investments no no so actually
to answer your question the most
expensive piece of clothing i got was uh
it was like a twelve hundred dollar suit
that i then spent i think another four
hundred dollars tailoring it so i was
all in sixteen hundred dollars on a suit
that i wore uh when i was a real estate
agent do you have any advice for us what
could we be doing better oh i wanted to
ask you how much you work
oh yeah man okay i wanted to ask you
that i used to work a lot now i mean i
still work a lot so now that i'm married
what i've done is i have taken chilled
out a little bit right i am taking some
more time off on weekends so actually a
lot of times the last few weekends i
haven't even worked
that much i mean i've been still doing
like emails a little other stuff on but
like not really going into the office
um and then monday through friday now
i'm working probably 8 a.m until
7 00 p.m
something like that but but
you know a lot of times when i'm not
working i am you know i'm talking about
work so like i'm thinking about work a
lot like that never goes away if we're
talking about the actual time in the
office you know that that's kind of what
it is but you know a lot of things that
i do i'm thinking about it like i like
to go on a morning walk in the mornings
um an hour and a half in the mornings
it's like five mile walk yeah i love
doing this before the sun comes up so
like i do like a little bit of
meditation at the beginning then listen
to audiobooks
and so it's like just learning right i'm
always learning always listening i was
kind of doing all that absorbing content
but that's kind of the way that i do it
love it thank you so much for coming on
that i really appreciate that that we
were able to do this finally after years
i know years literally no
thank you i really appreciate that thank
you nice meeting you thank you that was
great thank you thank you
uh what's getting your free stock down
below in the description center for
republic oh wow it's 7 55.
all right